Dänemark kommt seinen Verpflichtungen
der EU nicht nach wenn Dänemark mehr
geflüchtete im
solidaritätsverteilungsmechanismus
aufnehmen würde würden andere Länder wie
wir zum Beispiel auch Entlastung
bekommen also ehrlich muss man sich in
dieser Debatte dann auch machen wenn wir
diese Verteilung hinbekommen wir haben
es jetzt in einem großen
gesetzgebungspaket in der EU miteinander
beraten wenn die anderen Länder dann
solidarischer werden auch wie Dänemark
würde Deutschland sofort entlastet dafür
habe ich ja jetzt gekämpft und wir als
Koalition das wollen wir das ist zu
diesem konkretarität mit diesem konkret